Okay,
should be live here.
Put this on software and game
development.
Nice.
I've had some thoughts about the
algorithm.
We're going to see what we can do today
on it to um
to really get curriculum learning
working well.
got the Starlink. Nope. Starlink is here
Sunday.
Internet's okay for now. Welcome.
So, here's the uh the idea that I came
up with. I think we can actually use
advantage. I don't think we need a
separate learnability metric.
And uh the reason for this is that
advantage is somewhat self-correcting.
So if you get advantage that is too far
away from your current state, you'll
simply learn out of order. Yes, you'll
learn like a part of the level you're
not ready for, but that's totally fine
because that advantage will go to zero
and then you'll sample the stuff that's
nearby you.
And then the key is the way in which we
are um computing and updating advantage,
how we're keeping our estimates fresh.
And I also expect that we're going to
have to throw um some sort of
exponentially
moving average
because we don't want to kick stuff out
of the buffer too quickly.
That is the current idea.
I think this will be fine.
This is a quite nice
result here though.
Yeah, it's still using this masking
crap.
So, it's basically ignoring the thing I
said, but whatever.
Hey, Jess.
I'm doing all right.
The algo work is quite tiring. Oops, I
forgot my coffee. Let me grab my coffee.
I've just been doing some shorter
streams because the algo work really is
not something
that I can just grind for hours and
hours.
is decent so far.
What domain knowledge? There's still
some of this gating crap.
Um, but I think Jess, I see a path
forward here.
And uh it just it's actually not that
that far away from where we started, but
there are a few key distinctions that I
think would have been difficult to
discover
without doing all this stuff that we
did.
What if you don't mind me asking?
So,
it's still going to be based on
advantage.
I think that the key error that we made
in the original algorithm was storing
high advantage states instead of high
advantage segments.
you need to store the full segments even
though you're going to have very low
advantage. Maybe even like five or 10
steps before where you got the reward
because it gets heavily discounted.
But the thing is once you learn the tail
end like you learn the last few states
up to the goal, you're going to get
higher advantage a few states farther
out.
That was the key mistake. And then it
comes down to having good advantage
estimates, keeping them fresh, sampling
appropriately,
so on and so forth.
So, it just completely [ __ ] ignores
me and does some other random unrelated
thing cuz it's [ __ ] That's cool.
cursive.
Just ignore that. Dude,
it's funny in a sense cuz that's
actually a topic that I am very
interested in working on. But that like
the when I say those words, they don't
mean anything like what the hell they're
being used to describe currently.
Welcome, man. Thanks for joining,
Wolfpack.
We are working on the 5.0 Algo.
Contributor details.
Wait, what? Contributor details on Hang
on. What did you send me?
Oh, you just PR those man.
So, there is a list in the repository.
It's on the puffer.ai repo.
That's all you got to do.
That's the dock site
solving six pendulum cart pole.
I wouldn't be surprised if that works.
Puffer's pretty good.
I gave him a couple suggestions earlier
today.
raised it. Can you please check? Yep,
I got you.
Lick.
Oops. Let's just move this.
What is recursive? So,
I honestly think that the easiest thing
for like recursive self-improvement
would be you take an end of like net
hack where you should be able to make
basically linear progress and you try to
figure out why you're not making linear
progress.
I actually think that the stuff I'm
doing now would be
stuff like what I'm doing now actually
is probably the closest thing to
enabling that
So, actually this is very good if this
does still work, right?
No.
Just latching though.
14.
500 mil steps to learn. 15.
We got it right at the very end here.
Okay.
would do. Which AI company work do you
like most or have the most respect? I
mean, I have to say Puffer obviously,
right? I know that's not what you mean.
So, if you mean of the big labs, I'd say
Deep Mind, but not Deep Mind's language
model stuff, like all like everything
other than their language model stuff.
When can I play with the env on the
site? Um, I mean, if you want to like PR
to the site, that's fine. I mostly just
got stuck cuz I couldn't figure out how
to like test it locally with this stupid
Windows setup, and I haven't bothered
doing all the new M's on the laptop. I
have like six plus new ends now that all
need to go onto the site.
So, it's whenever I do the next big
batch of ends uploading.
So, this is expected to hard fail. Look,
this doesn't hard fail. like awesome.
Mhm.
Yeah. Main focus at the moment is this
algorithm.
All right. So, this crashes perfect
terribly.
want to relocate and work in US tech.
Are you not in the US right now?
Cuz the first step of that is get to the
US.
I'm not we're not doing Devon [ __ ] man.
[ __ ] that.
This is not like [ __ ] vibe code
stream. This is serious research stream.
I'm using this crap for prototyping cuz
it's like a whole bunch of CUDA edits
for what is essentially throwaway code.
I think that the key thing here
it just comes down to the handling of
update the handling and updating of the
advantage estimates in the sample
buffer.
Let's see if this helps.
South Asia uh India. Yeah, that one's
tough. You mostly have to figure out how
to get here.
Whether that's through school or work or
whatnot. That's the thing that you got
to figure out.
No, the models are completely stupid.
Like these things do not have a single
like this has not produced a single
useful idea in the entirety of doing
this algorithm.
In fact, this thing mostly tries to like
ignore me and do things that it thinks
will work better and [ __ ] things up in
the process.
When it comes to building a company,
don't ask me on that. I'm intentionally
making my life hard in that department
because I want to do what I want to do.
Why not use Claude? It's the same thing.
I'm sick of giving anthropic money.
Yeah, literally reinforcement learning
would still be as [ __ ] as it was like
3 years ago.
Um, there's been basically zero other
progress in the last 3 years on building
RL tools that actually work.
Nobody else wants to deal with this
crap.
Turbo Puffer. I mean, their product is
not relevant for the stuff that I do,
but it's always fun to see uh to see
them on X.
There's still several places we're using
domain knowledge, right?
Solve triggered segmented mission score
based retention.
Yeah, there's a bunch of crap. Most of
this is stuff that Codeex has done for
some [ __ ] reason, but I think a lot
of it's easy to ablade out.
Masters in US
undergrad is extremely selective and job
visa is a headache.
That's fair.
Masters in the US is annoying because
you have to pay for those.
Uh
maybe it's better for um
if you're from abroad.
I think for most US citizens it's
generally if you can get your masters
during your undergrad
a deal.
Well, yes, Jess, but you always have to
pay for undergrad. But like at some
places, you can just do your masters
during your undergrad.
Like in Stanford, you can graduate with
a masters in four years if you'd like.
like I didn't do I didn't do that
because I was going to do research
anyways. Um
but I spent probably half of my time in
all of undergrad doing research
and I graduated like two semesters early
or two trimesters early. the three and a
third years
basically. Well, a lot of PhD programs,
they'll just give you a masters halfway
through if you file one extra thing.
If you're already doing a PhD, a masters
is just like, ah, yeah, sure, whatever.
Here, have one, I guess.
Okay, this is getting annoying though
because this is now going from like
figure out algorithm to fight stupid
codecs and that pisses me off.
Let's see if this is stable. And then if
this is stable, I'll try to like prune
out some of the [ __ ]
Research and perception and computer
vision. Uh I no longer know the answer
to that. I could have answered that
question for you 10 years ago, but
nowadays I have no idea.
My adviser is still um does quite a bit
in vision.
You don't earn in dollars, euros
expensive.
Well, I mean, yes, like the US economy
is completely different.
Yeah. See, this is still [ __ ] like
just ignoring.
This is a light change though, so
possibly this is still fine.
Well, I mean, venture is not income,
though.
It's like raising $400 million does not
mean you make $400 million.
Yeah. Okay. Yep. They're completely
broken. H.
I mean, there's obviously stuff in
robotics. We've worked in
uh finance, commerce, little in
animation,
uh games, defense.
There are many areas.
Pretty much anywhere you have a heavy
interaction problem that's fiddly
unintuitive and you can write a fast sim
for
Yeah, this is still a ton of domain
stuff is kind of just [ __ ] added in.
What is an optimal way according to
wait optimal for this?
Wait, what? I don't know what that was
in response to.
This thing needs to not have um
dependence on score
basically anywhere. Even though you can
compute score for any MS, the way it's
using the score is very tied to this
specific task.
Like you can't compare score across
episodes and say this one has higher
score, so it's better.
That's not generally true.
You can do stuff based off of advantage.
That should be significantly more
robust.
Oh, my bad light. um
getting into that the thing is I don't
have any idea there like you should ask
people in the US who have done that
I mean If
if that means end to end is in the sense
like VLM or whatever everything no it's
[ __ ]
Like you literally have people
benchmarking
their VLMs now on problems that you
solve with a small like task specific
model in less than a second. It's
pathetic.
Okay, this was good.
This is
Okay, we get unlucky here because I
remember they were just not getting a 15
solve.
That's really annoying actually. I don't
like that
career, academic, techreated. I mean,
the articles that I have like are on the
educational side. That's the best. If
you're looking for traditional career
advice though, like I'm not exactly the
person to ask for that.
Oh, there we are. Okay, so we do get 15.
This matches from before.
Yeah, man. Good job with that. Like,
thank you very much for handling this
stuff in the last few days. Um, I'm
going to be honest. I haven't had like
the best hours the last few days, but
this algorithm stuff is just breaking my
head.
This is tough. Like, essentially,
this is what we have here. And there are
like four or five different points at
which there's domain knowledge still
being used in various different ways.
I'm basically just having to shift
things around and like pull like I'm
almost kind of like taking the different
chunks of the algorithm and pouring the
the like spots where it depends on
domain knowledge together so I have
fewer different sources of dependence on
domain knowledge. And I'm trying to
slowly replace bits of it that I can
with more general advantage based
metrics.
I'm honestly doing a very poor job of
even explaining what I'm doing on the
stream for the most part. But like
I don't think even the final algorithm
is going to end up looking particularly
complicated, but the process of
discovering it is just not easy.
Is it even reasonable to get rid of all
the I actually think it is. So the
reason for this is that advantage is
this like beautifully self-correcting
mechanism where as soon as you learn any
portion of the environment the advantage
at that point will drop to zero. So you
essentially have this automatic method
that tells you point in end that you
don't understand yet. Now it's not as
simple as just sample by advantage.
There are a whole bunch of issues with
that, but I'm slowly working around
them. And I've been making steady
progress in the last few days. like this
still trains and it has about a third of
the domain knowledge that it had 2 or 3
days ago.
programming and ML article. If you're
interested in more RL specifically, the
RL guide is how you get into the field
very seriously.
Um, that programming and ML article
though I recommend like coming back to
every so often because it's really all
of my best advice in one spot. It's my
single highest rated piece of content.
It's gotten some pretty cool
endorsements on it. Um,
basically all the useful stuff I can
give you as general advice is there.
That's a little uh
I don't know which three these were.
He's gotten a few, but
I don't know what the percentage is.
Oh yeah, anybody who's new around here,
feed the puffer a star on GitHub. It
helps us a lot.
Competitive RLS for laning.
I mean, it is kind of my good my uh my
party trick, right? This is sort of the
reason that people tend to stick around
is the the percentage of times where
like somebody will work on something for
a month and I'll look at it for 30
seconds and just be like, "Yeah, try
this." It's probably that.
Had a pretty good
success rate on those.
Not always, but I got a pretty good
success rate.
Like for instance, on this algorithm
here, I thought I was going to just be
able to do this in two days. And like I
actually think that the algorithm that I
came up with is going to be very close
to the algorithm that we end up with.
But just getting those last corrections
is very tricky.
Bas, do you think the company is worth
1.75 trillion.
Um,
like at least that number for that stuff
makes a hell of a lot more sense than
the crazy high numbers for these stupid
[ __ ] AI companies that all do the
same thing.
I mean, those are also both like
fairly new to being sizable companies.
Like neither of those had that many like
had those were both companies with
relatively very few employees only a few
years ago.
Is SpaceX is that just SpaceX or didn't
wasn't didn't they combine with
something else? Did they combine with X
or combine with something?
I mean actually that does make sense
combined with XAI.
Yeah, I mean at least that in my mind
that makes some sense, right? Like they
kind of do deliver
they are kind of crushing it on space.
You know,
you look at like what was it the mass to
orbit
versus everyone else the cost there?
Yeah.
I mean like when I see that I see a
crazy number behind something that's
also crazy cool. Like look at Nvidia's
valuation, right? Like that's a crazy
number behind something that's also
crazy good.
I think probably the portion of that
valuation that came from the XAI merge
is mostly [ __ ]
But then who knows? Maybe the original
was undervalued.
The [ __ ] do I know?
Yeah, I think the thing with XAI is um
like Elon's just doing too much stuff to
actually put in the time to understand
AI at the same level he understands his
other stuff.
and he's getting sold on like he's
having people sell him on like really
dumb [ __ ]
by these like very enthusiastic tech
bros that just have really really dumb
ideas.
Like I remember when they first
announced that their tech stack was
going to be Jax, TypeScript, and Rust. I
was like, "All right, these guys are
[ __ ] dumb, right?" And the funny
thing is now they actually have a really
good tech stack. It's just C and CUDA.
Um, but like that's no longer the flex
it would have been a few years ago
because now that probably just means
that they're vibe coding everything. So
like now it's like no longer the same.
It no longer holds the same significance
as before. Like if three years ago,
right, you told me that yeah, this is um
whatever AI company and they're doing
their own large models and their tech
stack is just C and CUDA.
Like I would think that they probably
have some good people just based on that
cuz there's kind of like a gate there
where you sort of have to not be a
complete imbecile to be working like in
that setup.
But that's no longer as true as it as it
used to be.
Hey Tim,
how to manage several open source
frameworks.
What in the actual [ __ ]
How to merge several open source
frameworks.
I have not heard of a single damn one of
those. I What on earth are you trying to
do, my friend?
I'll buy all the world class guys and
assume they were competent.
Yeah, you can't do that.
That's not how it works. There are a lot
of people that are just very overpaid
and very dumb.
graph rag etc.
What? Like what are you trying to do?
Like how can I merge? So you just listed
like a whole bunch of big bloated things
for like different purposes I guess and
then like you're asking me how to merge
a bunch of big bloated frameworks. Like
what are you doing?
I'd like to become a good engineer. I
know Python and C. What should I learn
next which will be useful?
That's basically it, my guy.
Like
you like you can pretty much do whatever
you want. I mean CUDA for GPU dev, but
that's mostly research.
If you read my article, I think like
most of the modern stacks are
essentially just [ __ ] around and waste
time
Yeah, I don't
I can't conceive of anything where you
would possibly need all that stuff at
the same time. like Don Street about
switching to C. Yeah, Crit and like I
said, it would be nice three years ago
before three years ago like saying this
is our stack meant you have good
competent engineers. Now it just means
you probably have people vibe coding
[ __ ]
It's still the right stack, but it's no
longer on its own means you're It no
longer on its own means you're doing the
right thing
or probably even doing the right thing.
World models in Japa.
Um, the way that world models are done
with RL is troll. It doesn't work.
I don't know JPA specifically, but most
of the RL world model that is borderline
scientific fraud.
Or at least I should say the most
well-known
world model that is just awful, awful
science. Looks super well written.
Doesn't [ __ ] work.
be a little bit more consistent. Then we
can ablate out the next chunk of things.
How to keep synergistic frameworks and
discard all the bloat.
Once you've picked any one of those, I
mean, I don't know all of those, but
just by assumption, like basically you
have too much bloat with one of those
already.
Like, there's no way to wrap a whole
bunch of giant bloated projects and not
have your thing be bloated.
The way that you have the way that you
do things without bloat is by
eliminating dependencies, not adding
them.
Still using scores domain knowledge.
Yes, Tim, but in a more restricted way
than we were doing before. We're working
on getting rid of it fully.
I think you Yan Lun is generally fine,
Jess. like let the guy go do his like
his crazy out there stuff. It's better
that we have people more people doing
crazy out there stuff than more people
just building the same stupid product
pretending to make God.
Like there's probably eventually some
highle low-level form of this that makes
sense Jess where like you can do a bunch
of training in sim fast
and very rarely need world model input
or something.
So it's good that they advance the
general world model stuff on its own
like without RL in the loop. That will
eventually be useful. It's just that the
current way that stuff is at being
attempted to be merged it doesn't make
sense.
Uh oh. Okay, this is kind of nice,
right? We got 12.
We'll see if this works nicely for us.
I can just increase the fraction
dedicated to CL. That would be super
nice.
Advantage reward be used instead of
score.
That's the idea, Tim. That's what we're
trying to do.
It takes very very many small ablations
to get it to there because when you try
the obvious thing that you would do
based on just advantage, it doesn't
work. So I've added a bunch of domain
hacks to get it to solve. And now we're
removing a bunch of domain hacks while
making sure that after each change it
still solves.
You see,
Where'd my uh browser go? Let just check
the stream.
We have
a few people on YouTube.
Hello
What is the which is a record?
Oh no, we've had like 200 plus
concurrent viewers before Jess on this
stupid vibe coding stream.
which is very funny to see like how
quickly you get a ton of viewers when
you're doing like the mainstream stupid
things. Not really an indicator of
anything.
Yeah, I think cuz like Twitch is more
there's more of a games audience
whereas YouTube is more general. So you
see have you have more people there for
technical content.
Mind you that the IPO days are um
usually quite volatile.
that we have reinforcement learning as a
whole? a stable, mature tech that just
you throw on any reasonably posed RL
problem and it just works,
works efficiently, works interpretably.
You have benchmarks across a wide range
of areas. You can build SIMs for a
variety of applications.
And then after that, we start going out
and solving some of those applications.
Other streams are more technical,
but like people were just giving me
stupid suggestions anyways. Liberty,
they were basically like, "Oh yeah,
press the button, man. Just press the
button."
We'll see if this is stable. If this is
not stable, then it's going to be very
awkward.
If this is stable but only gets like 14
or whatever, fine.
Flash goal.
Huh?
The point of this is like this the point
of this is not to [ __ ] around and like
do all the things with the model. Like
the point of this is to figure out this
algorithm. Like
the reason that people like recommend me
to do weird stuff with this is that they
don't understand the model is way too
stupid to like do anything that is
particularly helpful on the algorithm.
All right. The model is very stupid. The
model's currently just being used to
like prototype shitty CUDA things for
various ideas and then I'm and then I
run experiments and I like decide what
to do based on the outcome of those.
Like most of the stuff when I say like
[ __ ] model this, model that, it's not
that the model is like not smart enough.
It's that the model is explicitly
ignoring instructions.
longunning autonomous tasks. Yeah,
that's not what we're
and which segment is considered the
current frontier?
Okay, maybe this is the next thing to
remove.
Oh, see this is so annoying. So, what's
basically happened here is this [ __ ]
model has like just ignored instructions
a bunch of times and slipped a bunch of
stupid gates into the code that are all
like wired and tangled together now so
that I can't make reasonable changes
because they interact with stupid things
that aren't supposed to be here.
So, like,
not only are these models not useful for
coming up with like actual algorithmic
improvements, they actually aren't even
useful at following instructions
consistently.
Pain in the ass, man.
Hey, Cash, do you have the pendulum
thing solved yet? I posted some reward
stuff for you to try.
[ __ ] models, man. Let me think what I
can do with this.
See, this has just put me in a very bad
spot where like any change I make [ __ ]
with one of these stupid gates.
AI agents,
you shouldn't have enough code for um
heartpole for that to be an issue.
Like you should be able to implement
like the reward function I gave you
should be five lines of code or
whatever.
The thing I'm working on now is a pretty
fancy algorithm.
Uh yeah, don't do continuous action
spaces on puffer 4. There's uh there's a
bug in them. Uh I haven't there's a
patch I have, but I haven't merged it
in. There's like a very serious bug with
continuous actions bases on four.
What's the bug? It's something with
stability. It's like something in one of
the kernels where stuff can just get
unstable and collapse. I fixed it on a
client project, but I have to merge like
I have to go pull that patch out without
any client info
and upstream it.
We'll see if this solves. If this
doesn't solve, I won't be surprised.
But then I'm going to have to figure
something else out.
I hope they're paying you good.
Um,
let's just say we've increased our
prices quite a bit since um
since the last round of contracts.
Yeah, pretty much. Like that's kind of
the thing is it's not like certain
dollariz contracts are just no longer
worth the time that they take away from
research.
cuz we're getting very very close
um
on our core infrastructure.
Actually, if this does do better.
No, this should never do better. This
should only ever do on par.
So, we'll see.
I'll be happy if this just solves in the
two bill.
That reward is Wait, did this actually
help?
Oh, that's funny.
This is my favorite party trick is to
just look at problem and like come up
with something useful in 30 seconds.
I literally thought about that for like
30 seconds.
I mean, it's mainly just it deciding to
ignore instructions.
Reward shaping as a skill. It's not
really though is the thing man.
Very very little of what we do is reward
shaping
like this is no longer some blackbox
arcane skill in my head. This is
actually something that's very simple
and
um
it it's generally very simple and
consistent now.
It's really not shaping so much
like
It's more so I just think I'm just like
looking at the reward and thinking what
like what strategy matches that reward
and like seeing how it's obviously
stupid and broken. Like in your case,
Tim, you can put something on like you
can just push something past the target
and you get the same reward.
like this delta type based reward is
just like a common fix for it. It's
quite simple.
Come on, solve.
I think even if this doesn't this is
still kind of okay.
I think I just need to describe like
smaller changes as all
last time when I tried Claude Code.
Oh, that was the worst dream ever.
You What you think?
Like I literally just switched to Codeex
because I was sick of giving anthropic
money. and whatever. It really should
not. If you're so dependent on using
like codeex versus and like clawed, it's
probably because you have zero value add
over the model.
It should be the other way around
where the model has minimal value add
over you.
We'll see if this completely crashes
Perf or not.
If we can get rid of the frontier
mechanic entirely.
This might Okay, if this screws it up,
then the hypothesis that we're is going
to be that we're still too tied to score
over advantage.
If this fails, I actually will not be
surprised.
Sim to real cartpole when cartpull six
when
I actually wonder how good your physics
have to be for that
it's probably they don't have to be as
good as you would Fact.
Um, it may or may not for that convert.
This is a chaotic system.
If it if it's actually tough to use that
approach there, I wouldn't be surprised.
But there's almost nothing that actually
looks like this. Like very very few
systems that you care about and you're
doing control on are chaotic.
Why are we stuck on level four with no
signal?
Okay. If this actually does solve,
that's quite nice for us
because then we don't have Frontier like
Frontier completely gone. That's big.
We'll make a This is like worth making a
commit on.
Are we just getting unlucky on
exploration or something?
We still don't have a single level 13
solve.
That could be the other change on CL
segments.
We'll try that next.
As long as this gets like 13 14.
Oh, is that
just got the 14 exploration
the patch is pretty slow here.
That's not ideal.
a lock?
Uh, I have not yet convert.
I will give it a shot though with um
like four versus five because we need
some tests for that.
I'm pretty well locked to this one
though, at least until I finish these
oblations.
I won't be surprised if this fails. This
is this change will be needed, but it
might be too early.
What three ocean m are solid for testing
serious work?
Well, testing what? So, definitely not
pong. Pong is too simple. Breakout is
the enemy you use for testing very quick
changes or for testing if you've made
anything slower or not, as well as for
testing if an algorithm gets you um like
a new speedun.
2048 is a hard env. It requires quite
some compute, at least at the moment.
Um,
Nurmo3 is the really hard one where you
typically just run it once at the end
and you see if that um if you manage to
soda it.
We have several others. It depends what
you're doing.
Not going to be like one good answer
though. Pong is basically never the
correct choice.
hyper patterns
solvable for a range of maybe mazes.
But the thing is like,
yeah, maybe it's still mazes. This
Soon is not a slow env. It's just that
it's hard.
This is also with crap hypers, by the
way.
Okay, we're alive.
Fix this stupid camera.
It'll come back on in a second. How much
hypers can make a difference?
What experiments causing an ablation to
fail? Yeah. So, Tim, we're just assuming
that we don't have optimal anything.
And um we're trying to solve anyways.
You can't run a sweep in between each
thing. You can only run sweeps to verify
sets of changes.
So the unit of compute
for the purpose of showing anything
is uh the unit of compute for
experimentation is a sweep. The unit of
compute for [ __ ] around and like
trying to get a sense of stuff is still
an experiment.
So there's a little asterisk on like we
never run individual experiments. We
never run an individual experiment
that's like ah yes this experiment shows
this outcome, right? We run experiments
for like digging at stuff.
Pathfinder board game.
Nope.
I know. Pathfinder DND.
moved or hit a wall. I haven't seen that
convert.
Okay, I think it's doing way too much
crap,
but whatever.
We'll try it this way.
Oh, no. Actually, that's fine. It had
done it a stupid way previously. Cool.
That's fine. Actually,
we'll try Yes.
Okay,
I'm going to try this real
that's like that has some potential
What was this awful ad?
Okay.
Oh, okay. I see how this works. That's
funny.
That's like a combination of battleship
and corridor.
That's cool.
just completely [ __ ] ignored me. But
cool if this works like yay.
I don't think this does quite work. I
think it's going to be like couple
levels short, but
what do you mean how would you do the
obs? It's like the easiest thing ever to
do obs for, man. You could literally
just make it the full board and just
zero out anything that's unknown
or like not like uncunk out anything
unknown, right?
This is easiest thing ever to do.
Obvious
Yeah. See, this is not this is not it
here. Um,
it's close.
Not quite it though.
I don't know if Codeex is on it is not
uh I don't know how encouraging that is
but all right
okay that's definitely um
that's definitely concerning Okay.
I mean, the only thing that I might do
that would be like a relatively longer
running thing, man, would be like, let's
say that I get the uh the algorithm
fully working, right? Obviously, the
code is going to [ __ ] suck because
it's just codeex crap. What I might do
is I might make a commit there and then
point it at the original 40 and have it
minify the diff. So get the minimum diff
while still keeping the score the same
or the behavior the same. I might do
that to give myself a starting point to
be editing it
with a minimal code change, but I don't
even know if that'll be reasonable.
What RL product would you recommend a
college student to build? Check out my
guides. I've got lots of educational
stuff on my articles tab on X.
You pretty much just start building some
environments. Start with something
really simple, work up to something more
complex.
The best way to learn. It's how most of
the people around here got into uh into
RL.
Okay. So, this is fine. This should be
generic. It's just doing it in a stupid
way.
Yeah, it's just being stupid. This is
fine. Like, this should be equivalent.
It It used domain knowledge for no
[ __ ] reason.
Like, let it be known the models are
dumb.
I'd way rather have the enthusiastic
intern. Speaking of which, I got to chat
with Finn soon. He should be just about
finishing up exams.
Okay,
we'll double check this in a second.
Costing us time.
by this.
Welcome Kellix.
So, if we're going to say that this is
reasonable enough,
which we still have to see, it's very
close.
PvP prefers
2K hidden in 20 replay ratio.
It typically does that when your NV is
slow.
So, if your env is already slow to begin
with, it'll typically make it even
slower so that it spends um it's
basically keeping the GPU constantly
saturated.
20 replay ratio is nuts though.
I have seen it get pinned to four before
and it's typically when you have the
NVIS too slow or if you have it like
pinned to one thread or whatever one
core
that'll do
vers selfplay
if you send me over a couple videos.
Also, have you like tried it to make
sure it makes sense?
Like, can you cheese it? Can you just
like one tick whip it or whatever?
this is why the um RSMs are not as good
for like research dev, like this
algorithm dev phase, because there's
just too much stuff going on.
They're going to be more useful for like
testing out the algorithm once done on.
There's 15.
Okay, we're good.
All kinds of cheeses
don't seem gameable. I'm not getting
over 50% against my hel opponent.
That's cool.
I'm trying to think who we could get
that would be fun to like try this
against
well send over some clips and I still
need to draft that email. I'm going to
do that pretty soon.
come chipping away and having
confidence.
Well,
the thing is Tim, in this case,
like
this specific direction, it's basically
impossible that there isn't something
you can do that's very close to what I'm
doing that will work. And then it's
mostly a matter of figuring out in a
consistent replicable way what are the
ex what's the exact version of this that
is required.
I uh
I used to be okay at NH,
And then I literally failed. I think I
like three tick gol killed somebody at
alter.
yesterday.
Some random scrubby pure.
I will say I really like that account
that I made.
We got rid of the domain knowledge in
the history. We got rid of the frontier
domain knowledge.
It's actually very easy to not drop
ticks in PvP Volo. But like even
literally the best in nature drop ticks
in order to um to hit off prayer.
He only has a few clips, but he's like
very good.
yeah, I think even the very best PKers
will occasionally miss that stuff or
like um
like they're very small things you can
do
like for instance um
always having on Argory
on opponent hit ticks if you're not also
hitting same tick.
There are things like this you can do
that just really crank your APM high if
you do everything.
Valo, have you seen like he doesn't
really have many videos anymore, but
like um have you seen Panax clips?
one YNA is even better. Yeah, Panic says
that um one YNA is probably the best.
He did a really funny tier list video
and yeah, he he basically says it's him
1013 and why uh one ya. Yeah. Was it
Lina?
I don't know.
The only annoying thing is like of those
three only panic has a lot of clips.
1013 and 1 y and a like they both have a
few clips but not really a ton.
Oh any one backwards. That's funny
Kevin.
Well, that's confusing cuz Kevin framed
is also Kevin.
I think 1013 is like the fastest player,
isn't he?
At least for an H.
The stuff he does just does not look
human.
Framed is old. No.
No. Framed is good, but he's Yeah. Okay.
I mean, he's like very good by like
normal human standards.
and there's a lot of ticks waiting
around.
I think it's mostly because like a lot
of the top people just assume that you
will hit on attack cooldown every time
and then they immediately start doing
stuff after they've changed prayer for
that tick. So if you like wait one tick,
you can very often get people
off prey. Okay.
That is a very cool sim though for
selfplay if you get it stable. Um,
now that'll be very nice to chuck in all
the latest stuff on because you don't
have to the historical selfplay things
in, right?
Um, well, Oda just doesn't like he just
doesn't NH a lot, right?
So, he's like very very good all around,
but he just doesn't NH
like the few people who really just do
That
With that guy, it feels more like it's
just the world moves at onetenth speed
for him or thing.
Okay, this is good. Hopefully we get
this solve here, but I think we're fine
either way.
be nice if we could get this one just uh
for certainty, but if we don't get a
random lucky,
it's kind of Okay.
Well, there we go. Yeah, it's about to
solve. Boom. That's a super quick latch.
Okay, I'm happy with this.
admission trigger segment score is
like so
Okay. So then there's really just one
last thing to ablate. We have We're down
to literally
the last thing that we have to solve
now. I'm gonna say we're down to like
maybe a fifth of the domain knowledge
that we started with.
Admission trigger
segment score.
lost track most of the domain. It's
pretty much just using the score in um
like admitting like using the score and
the reward to decide what segments to
keep and what segments to retain which
that might seem generic cuz you can
always use reward. But the thing is um
that's because specifically for this end
the rewards are always going to be
informative. a higher reward or a
shorter length episode is always better.
That is not true in the general case.
Advantage is much much more stable and
consistent across ends for things like
this.
So, we're working on it. Top K pretty
much, Tim. But it's top K according to
um according to score. It needs to be
something on advantage.
We're getting close.
segment average advantage.
Um, that's actually not really what you
want though. It's actually that's going
to be the same. Well,
it's not quite what you want probably.
We'll see.
some seg. So those would be equivalent
because the segments are the same
length.
There's a little bit of nuance to it
though.
The final thing is going to end up being
pretty clean and simple, but I'm like
there are a lot of different things I'm
considering in the process of doing this
crap.
Okay.
So, if this doesn't work,
well, at least now we basically have all
the conflating crap out.
Domain spec. We will see. Jess,
I'm trying.
Is it 100 p.m. now?
Not bad.
If you do it on score,
it's basically taking solved
trajectories. Yep.
So advantage is nice, Tim, because
the thing with score is it assumes that
if you have two episodes and one has
higher score than the other, it's
better. Same same with reward. That is
not true across ends, especially
randomized ends where sometimes some
episodes are harder than others. So
advantage is way more comparable across
episodes regardless of end dynamics.
like state CL.
What version of it, man?
Um,
it's not so much actions better than
expected. Advantage greater than zero
means that following the policy from the
current state resulted in a better
outcome in the next however many
discounted steps as expected.
You can't have a high advantage segment
that gives bad information. No.
Likewise, a a negative advantage segment
is also useful in a different way.
tidbits from puffer.
Yeah, but Jess, I'm kind of like
I'm kind of like trying to push the core
algorithm stuff. All the education stuff
I do is nice and it does help Puffer,
but I can't just be doing pure education
stuff.
The goal is to push the frontier.
I will say that doing this research this
way genuinely feels awful.
Like this is like trying to like this is
trying to get like a malevolent genie to
do all your low-level tasks. It's still
technically faster cuz I'm prototyping
in CUDA. Like that would take a while,
but [ __ ] is it annoying?
Yeah. So, it's just following
instructions incorrectly half the time
is the problem. Now, the good news is
what I've done is I've managed to
isolate down to a small enough number of
things that I can actually track and see
what it's [ __ ] up. So, we're very
close to being able to fix this now.
cuz like essentially there are only two
places where it's actually using domain
knowledge and there's some surrounding
crap but way less than there was before.
So before it had a whole bunch of places
that were sneaking domain information in
redundantly and it was very difficult to
isolate any changes from those. But I've
managed to do that and now pretty much
just using the score to determine what
segments go into the buffer and then
using score to determine what segments
are retained in the buffer. So what I
can do is if I can make it be advantage
determines what segments go into the
buffer. That's minus one place. And then
we just have to figure out this last one
sampling retain metric which is much
easier
should be at least
Yeah, it's still doing this [ __ ]
[ __ ] isn't it?
Okay, so this may work. We'll see. This
is getting rid of one of the remaining
gates.
We'll try without this if this one
works.
We also made everything way [ __ ]
slower. So, good job, Codeex.
We'll see if this works, though.
11. Halfway through at 11
maybe.
We will see.
We will try summed advantage next
instead of max.
12.
Okay, we're getting close. We're getting
very close.
Okay.
Um, this is also not terrible because we
are getting to 13 now.
It's not latching fast enough, that's
for sure.
I'll let it rerun this trial
uh in a moment and then I'm going to
take a short break, grab a drink and
whatever maybe
while this runs.
Oh yeah, for anybody who's new around
here, if you have not starred puffer on
GitHub, what are you doing? Star the
puffer. It's free. puffer.ai, star the
puffer. He eats stars. He's hungry.
13's not good enough, but
we'll see if we get 13 in fast this
time.
It's not latching fast enough with this
new um metric for sure. So presumably
just max advantage is net
to play with it.
Okay, cool. So, we have a very nice
metric here. Don't let me forget to
unmute my mic. I'm going to let this
run. I'll be right back.
All right.
11.
Not too good.
It is faster.
at least I think we'll see like how much
sensitivity there is to the exact form
of advantage we're using.
was today's agenda. We are trying to get
all the domain knowledge dependence out
of our state set algorithm.
There are two places that we're still
relying on environment score instead of
advantage.
And uh we are ablating a few different
ways of doing it with advantage until we
find one that works.
solid eight.
All right, this may or may not be
better. We will see.
I think we can take some time to sort of
just think while we do this. Um,
so if you admit segments that have
reward
Segments that have reward would have
solves in them.
I can only really think of some
advantage. If this doesn't do better,
I'm not actually going to know what to
do with this.
It would be quite weird. I guess we'd go
looking for other explanations. Um,
we'll see. Maybe we'll get something out
of this.
I'm not too uh I'm not too hopeful
though.
segment that has high advantage versus
segment that has
it. Seems pretty odd to me if there's
going to be a huge difference here.
Let me have it go look over. It probably
just added some dumb thing without me
seeing it.
Okay, it's doing some weird [ __ ] That's
fine. We'll figure it out.
We'll figure it out.
Yeah, it's doing a bunch of really
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
Like, it just added all of this crap
without me noticing somehow.
Stupid models, man.
I guess we'll have to reflect on this
after this project is done because it's
incredibly frustrating. Then
Like this [ __ ] isn't supposed to exist.
This [ __ ] isn't supposed to exist. This
[ __ ] isn't like none of this [ __ ] is
supposed to exist.
Yep. So, it just came up with something
completely [ __ ] dumb
somehow.
I almost I'm actually starting to wonder
if this thing is even worth using.
I mean, it just does so much stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ]
And then I'm sure that the second 5.6
comes out, some idiot is going to be
like, "Oh, bro, yeah, if you use a 5.5,
of course it's dumb. Yeah, that model
sucks." Even though two weeks ago I said
it was the smartest PhD level, world
class, whatever.
I'm not even trying to get it to do
anything complicated. It's basically
just like wellescribed edits to existing
codebase on the order of like I don't
know 20 to 50 lines at a time.
like the major like mainstream AI has
basically just be become cigarette
agency ads.
The thing is you can't even send any
metrics to wand like you have to very
very heavily
um down sample metrics otherwise w just
dies.
Great.
Idiot model.
Somehow this version is also not solving
which is really bad.
Luckily I made commits
I think this is going to have to be a
revert. We'll same
Don't rely on s cosine.
What do you mean?
Well, that's just cuz the model's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
It tends to do well on trivial [ __ ]
sometimes and it tries to [ __ ] it tends
to [ __ ] up anything of sufficient
complexity.
Kinvert, it would should take you less
than 6 hours to write the damn thing
from scratch.
old man.
Well, I mean, [ __ ] think, man. It's
like if it's going to be like let the
thing like go spin for an hour, produce
utterly dog [ __ ] [ __ ] code, and then
spend 6 hours trying to salvage it into
a reasonable state. Then the models are
crap and need to be yeetated as far as
possible. Oh,
Yeah, it's codeex
thing is crap. True that you finished
CS. I did the core in a year
and then I think I graduated in three
years and one quarter. So I spent
probably half of my time in the
remaining
three and a quarter year three and
whatever 3 years plus a quarter on
research.
Like it's not hard to finish the core in
your first year. It's literally two
classes a semester.
I think just the main thing that pisses
me off is
the way that the AI companies are
basically behaving like cigarette CEOs.
um and just constantly [ __ ] lying
about everything.
If it was like, "Hey, the models are
crap, but they're still kind of useful
tools." Like, that'd be one thing, but
that's not what's happening at all.
Subjects did you take? It's just six
core classes split among a bunch of
stuff.
And then like obviously I took more than
just that,
right? But those are the core classes. I
What else did I do?
I don't know. like two, three, maybe
two, two to four other things in CS,
plus a lot of the breath things.
very irritating day. Like, we're making
progress and I'm having no fun. It's
like we're actually making a lot of good
progress, but this is just [ __ ]
painful.
Well, I mean, the current way CS toss is
b is taught is basically dick you around
a whole bunch and teach you nothing and
you can finish that in two years. Sure.
Like my systems courses sucked so badly
that I didn't touch C for a decade
or C++ for that matter. There.
Um,
I'd actually imagine that all the ones
in the middle are where you're wasting
your time in
cuz community qual college qualifies you
for any job that needs a college degree
in anything.
And at least going to a top school. It's
like, okay, you have a credential for
whatever the [ __ ] that's worth, even if
there's like a whole bunch of [ __ ]
and stuff could be taught way better.
And then all the stuff in the middle is
just like, eh, [ __ ] you.
The fact this isn't reproing is very
bad.
Yeah,
I know. I committed this thing at 15
score.
It could have broken determinism, I
suppose.
I'm obviously not going to push this
with determinism broken just
like for um for actual 5.
I wouldn't be surprised if it did.
That's a very easy thing to break.
See, but now I don't know what the [ __ ]
to do because if we can't repro this
It's This thing's [ __ ]
Where is it trying to roll back to?
I [ __ ] hate these models. Jesus
Christ, man.
We're going to get this into a stable
spot and I'm just going to do [ __ ]
manually because like we're making like
pretty damn good progress today and
instead of being like happy or excited
about my work, I want to put my [ __ ]
face through the nearest wall. It's like
god damn it, man. [ __ ] these models.
It's just trying to roll back all the
way to yesterday.
Now, of course, the problem is this is
like that employee that writes such dog
[ __ ] code that like you can't even fire
the [ __ ] without canceling the whole
project.
We literally just need to invest more
time in having good simple hand
optimized kernels for everything and
less like dog [ __ ] a optimi AI optimized
10 times longer like garbage monsters.
That's it.
Cuz that's the reason I'm even having to
do this crap in the first place.
This isn't even code failure though.
This is like follow basic ass
instructions failure.
views go up with raged LMS. It's like
[ __ ] so annoying, man.
It can probably figure out where it
broke the determinism, but it's like
[ __ ]
It doesn't use that.
Yeah. Look.
This would have done it. This would have
done it
because this is actually good. Okay.
And now we get 15 solved.
I'm sure this is going to end up being
stupid and slow. We'll see.
The fact that it's that janky is bad. We
need to improve the stability.
Do we get the same rewards?
16.419.
We want to make sure every single one of
these is latching quickly.
Let's see if we have any long latch
sections.
If we don't have any long latch
sections, we'll consider this table and
we'll continue.
So what? We just never get a a T12
solve. Is that what's happening?
There it is. There's the solve. Now
latch. Boom. Instantly latches.
Okay. So, if anything, we're just
getting wrecked by exploration.
level 15 is quite hard to learn.
Come on.
So, 15 is a little iffy. Other than
that, the 1.3 bill
Huh?
I mean, we just got we got 14 of the
levels. They basically as soon as you
got a single lucky solve, they latched
on very quickly. One of them not so
great. So, there's something to improve
there, but it's pretty darn good.
Oh, hang on. Advantage itself is tied to
the policy, isn't it?
I think I see the issue. Okay, that
challenges things a little bit.
No, unfortunately, Jess, because the
code is still [ __ ] like I can't edit it
by hand because it's made such a mess.
But for the algorithm part, no, the
algorithm part, I actually I have some
ability to think about things now, at
least for a few minutes here. And I have
about three more hours to stream.
No, cuz I have to eat dinner at 6
at 2 hours and change.
You You can't update the advantage
estimates of your segments, can you?
the advantage calc itself is for is on
policy.
That's the issue.
So we can reuse states but we can't keep
reusing advantages.
Okay, that's a really dumb mistake on my
part.
The thing is this does not invalidate
the algorithm one bit. It just means
that we have to use advantage slightly
differently.
Five. Are there jobs for cleaning up
Vive Code?
But the only valid response to hating
the damn timeline is making a better
one. So, that's what we're going to do.
Arl's going to be [ __ ] sane. The code
is not going to suck. The algorithm is
going to kick ass. And then we're going
to go solve a bunch of actually
important problems with it.
Okay, here's sort of what I'm thinking,
guys, right? Um, we can't update the
advantage estimate for a segment
once we record it.
Oh, that's not exactly true. Excuse me.
We can't recmp compute advantage on the
same segment with a different policy.
That's not valid.
we have to just decay advantages over
time.
Yeah, there's a way to do this.
It just took some insight. We'll get
that. We will get it.
Let it be known though that like
the model did not point this out. The
model has no [ __ ] idea.
I had to kind of like think about it and
go, "Oh, wait.
If this passes
then I will be interested to see
Why are we completely failing to latch
all 10?
I need a [ __ ] drink.
Today is a good day for margaritas with
dinner.
I think it's just a bunch of like these
huristics are conflicting. Jess, it's
very difficult to like locally perturb
this thing.
Uh, from the place I get my dinner from
normally, their margaritas are really
good.
longlasting boutique.
The [ __ ]
last couple things need to be
generalized.
I'm trying to think if I just have to
oneshot it from here cuz it's like
basically any individual local change I
can make is going to conflict with some
other [ __ ] that we have.
Okay,
I see the issue. Let me just think a
little bit.
It has to do with replacing
advantage estimates for old segments.
We have to make it not super complicated
as well.
It's difficult cuz like anything that
exploits reward, it's really subject to
stocastic kind of dynamics,
Okay,
we're going to have to make some
changes.
has to do with replacing the tails of
the um
These are a lot of changes. We'll see.
This is kind of a yellow change, but
like
Well, also, we're going to have to think
about this quite a bit, but
I think the shortening tails idea is
good.
Hang on. Let me look up where the hell
this place is that my friend just says.
Oops. Sorry folks. I'm just answering a
couple messages on the side here. I'll
explain in a moment.
It's actually a friend who does
curriculum learning that I got to talk
to about curriculum learning.
We just had a general learnability
metric, we'd just be set, wouldn't we?
We're going to have a problem with RNG,
aren't we?
We'll ignore that for now.
If there's a general learnability. Yeah,
that's fair.
All right, we'll see if this does
anything.
So, this version is intended to find
faster solves. Basically,
it's intended to find faster solves
or faster and faster solves for the same
thing.
If this solves, I'm going to have to
think about it a bit.
taking it a long time to get. Yeah,
there we go.
Then the latch.
There we are.
latches very quickly from any solve
rate.
Okay,
here it is.
You can see from this it'll latch like a
few seconds later.
This needs to start actually solving.
All right. So, this is not bad
especially for a first refactor.
So, now we have to think about this
metric.
So the key is you don't want to replace
you don't want to replace a trajectory
segment
with like one that has higher advantage
or higher whatever but starts later.
So I think improving the tail
of um improving the tail
of a segment.
That should be a pretty nice general
thing.
the thing that's a little difficult is
that we're how we're determining what is
improving the tail of a segment
cuz we're using score at the moment
and that is you're at the mercy of RNG
for ends with stoasticity. We are
basically just looking for lucky
dynamics.
So, we're going to have to patch that.
If we assume that we can patch that, do
we have the algorithm?
Can't do it based on advantage, can we?
Tough.
You just screw up the value function if
you do it this way, don't you?
Okay, we need to solve that.
We have kind of the trial version of the
algorithm I would say There.
I mean, this is the wonderfully stupid
and simple algorithm,
but um
issues with it.
What's an example of learnability? There
isn't a good one.
It's the white whale thing that would
sol. It's like a fixion, you know.
Ah, the Fixion particle. It fixes all
the things we don't understand. Yay.
Look that one up.
Maybe we do one episode return. We'll
see.
I guess one other thing we could do is
like
we get a segment that solves
also seal nut segments not being able to
replace other CL segments is annoying.
There's a little bit of robustness to
RNG manipulation with this one. actually
if your end is full deterministic.
Well, then you can [ __ ] RNG manip
anyways,
We can fix that.
Wait, if this thing can't gig giga R and
GMF
might be good enough. What are you
working on now? Working on the state set
algorithm.
Now, okay, the thing that I really don't
like, right, is that
replacing the tails
of segments with higher episode return.
We cannot we cannot justify admitting
segments
based on score.
I'm going to give it this log and see if
it can figure out why it's not latching
12.
We'll do some ablations, log based
ablations on the current one. And then I
think what it is going to have to be,
it'll be advantage based uh advantage
based admission.
Probably something like that, like
advantage based admission.
Yeah. Okay, we're back on track. We're
back on track.
so I think that this is good, Right? If
we imagine that the algorithm it works
like this. We admit into the buffer high
advantage segments.
We improve those segments
by replacing their tails
with higher return
with segments that get higher episode
return. I think that's good.
possibly discounted.
I think that's good.
I think that's the algorithm.
That should be pretty robust.
We'll go think about whether that should
break on a bunch of van.
It does allow you to very slightly RNG
manip.
And we also have to find an eviction
policy, but that one's not bad.
Literally, they just like proudly admit
that they're just vibe coding their
entire [ __ ] company.
yeah. Okay,
that's insane.
That's ridiculous.
Any
actual research?
No.
186 gram.
That near half a pound.
All right. We got any results? We have
Yeah, this is just a diagnostic.
Anyways,
And I'll run this. I'll run one other
thing. I'm going to grab a drink as
well.
I think we're very close here. We got to
figure out this latching thing.
And then it's mostly just the admission.
Then there's actually that's like 10%
domain knowledge left, right?
Because I actually think the score-based
tail improvement thing is pretty
general.
We'll figure we'll figure that out
shortly as well. I still have like an
hour
end a little early depending how I'm
feeling, but this is going pretty well.
Frustrating as hell day.
I'm sure absolutely none of this code
will be able to be used directly,
but as long as we can figure out the
core algorithm, I'm happy.
and like reduce the number of
implementation details needed as well.
admission retention is too selective
under the discounted return rule.
Fresh M saw a huge number of solve
candidates.
Only 547 segments were inserted.
shorter lower endpoint segments over
deeper endpoint segments.
That's not how discounted return works.
right, there's a restroom. Grab a drink.
I'll be right back and we will continue
for a little bit.
Yeah.
probably sampling.
Uh, we're close, Jess.
We're very close.
What keyboard?
An old Razer one.
This a turny edition.
They're nice. You can get better
keyboards, but these are This
Let's see if this does it just on its
own.
If we can get something that at least
solves, I can I can refine it from here.
Cuz now,
okay, we do need to think about the
advantagebased admissions.
We'll just see the last few level solve
times.
14 14.
It's actually way more reasonable solve
times though.
It's way more reasonable.
Oh, look. That's constellation.
That's why I occasionally have to check
the site
cuz we do have to do a little bit of
promo for the puffer.
We'll try this real quick. Uh, one or
two other more things and that's about
it.
Well, of course, actually that change I
made would make latching worse, but it
should improve the time to get samples
into the buffer.
I think we're going to come out about
even.
Yeah, it ends up being 14.
We have the 15. We do have No, we don't
have the 15 segment. I think it ends up
just being about even.
Okay. Nope. You don't end up solving
from this. Cool. So, it's very close.
I'm trying to think how we figure this.
Uh
I mean, this is flailing.
I'm It's towards the end of the day,
though, and I'm getting tired. I'm out
of ideas.
I just want to have a stable version of
this we can commit. At this point, I
think we're very close. I have to think
about the advantage
save mechanic,
but this is now basically like onetenth
of domain knowledge left.
This might also just be too high entropy
to train. Well, we'll see. But I think
we were mo mostly just not getting the
lucky solves. So, we will see.
Still no. Huh?
Well, we get to the same spot as before
and we just never get a lucky um 15
solve. I guess
the latches are actually pretty
reasonable as well.
That's kind of odd.
Okay. Well, we're pretty close here, I'd
say.
We have like a tenth of the the damn
domain knowledge left.
I don't know why you're trying to just
full on like just auto vibe code stuff.
Like what are you doing, dude?
But we still need to figure this [ __ ]
out. Trying to learn how to That's not a
thing, dude. There's no trying to learn
how to get results from the LLMs. It's
not a skill issue.
There's no [ __ ] skill like whatsoever
involved with these LLMs. The only skill
is do you actually know what the [ __ ]
you're doing?
Like as an engineer and as a programmer
in general, there's literally no skill
whatsoever.
The whole LLM like skill issue dialogue
is [ __ ] [ __ ] It's a bunch of
midwits. Don't be one of them.
Okay, so
let me give a quick summary of the
algorithm as we have it today as we've
made a whole bunch of good progress. Um,
the current algorithm works like this.
You have a state buffer. It contains
several trajectory segments.
When you uh finish segments in training,
you store the top k highest scoring
segments according to summed to reward.
You store the states associated with
those segments into the buffer.
Those cannot those segments in the
buffer cannot get overwritten by other
uh other segments from the buffer. Uh
what it means by this is when you sample
when you sample starting states from the
buffer
you cannot overwrite other segments that
are in the buffer already with them.
However, if you sample a starting state
and you come up with a higher discounted
return
solve from wherever you start to the
tail of the segment that can get added.
So essentially this allows you to find a
higher scoring or shorter solves
from the state that you added.
I think that this is fairly general
because this is iterative improvement on
a given trajectory.
I think that is fine. I think that the
chunk that is still not general is
adding st adding segments to the buffer
based on score
because different episodes are not going
to be necessarily the same score norm.
Some episodes may be harder, some
episodes may be easier. You know, you
can have randomized starting ends. So I
think that the addition of states into
the buffer needs to be based on
advantage and then the improvement of
segments in the buffer needs to be based
on score. That is where we are at the
moment. We're very close to the original
PF. Um a little little bit lower but
only 10% of the domain knowledge.
I am pretty tired today.
Well, I'm tired from like bullshitting
like typing crap in a codeex all. It's
just a really dumb, unengaging way to do
stuff.
Um, we will tough this out for a few
more days before we get to do actual
real engineering though.
Uh, for folks who are new around here,
I do stream all of my research. I also
stream some like actually cool fun
engineering once in a while. Uh,
puffer.ai, we got all sorts of fun
demos. We got constellation. We got all
our M's. If you want to support us for
absolutely free, Star Puff are on
GitHub. You can join Discord to get
involved. It's all open source. You can
follow on X or more reinforcement
learning content, including all my
educational